bonjour je m'appelle baussillon des
mal-logés 20 ans j'habite à saint denis
je recherche un emploi dans la vente
dans le commerce j'ai obtenu assez ap
d'employé de commerce multispécialités
et j'aimerais travailler en vente
par exemple dans les rayons de boissons
j'ai effectué pas mal de stages en
entreprise j'ai pu découvrir
des choses que je savais pas faire comme
faire la mise en veille ont fait le
fascine les types étage dépôt de
palettes gérer les stocks je suis
actuellement formation de garantie jeune
formation de la mission locale j'ai
l'expérience dans l'espace vert quand
j'ai effectué
neuf mois de service civique à la villa
départementale au conseil général dans
la rue de paris donc voilà je suis
souriant je suis motivé dynamique je
recherche du travail actuellement
n'hésitez pas à me contacter je suis
prêt à donner le meilleur de moi même